d'un papillon et professeur agrégé en
sciences politiques à l'université de
montréal bonsoir vous vous intéressez à
la question de la participation
autochtone dans la gestion des
ressources naturelles au canada est au
coeur de cette affaire s'est construit
grâce link bien sûr ce grand projet de
gaz naturel de 6 milliards et demi de
dollars
comment ça se passe les bas
l'élaboration de projets comme celui de
construire gas link mais c'est un
processus qui est très long le processus
dure plusieurs années et donc le
processus d'approbation de ce projet là
on passe par plusieurs étapes
lorsque si c'est un projet qui relève de
la compétence la colombie-britannique
donc c'est un projet d'app reçu une
approbation qui relève la province
il ya un processus d'évaluation des
impacts d'un projet il ya un peu un
processus aussi de deux consultations
avec les nations autochtones et en
parallèle à sommes maintenant de plus en
plus les compagnies minières mais aussi
pétrolières ou qu'ils construisent au
lieu de deux comme ça des
infrastructures vont négocier des
ententes avec les communautés
autochtones
j'entends tout le partage des bénéfices
des revenus qui sont générés par ses
infrastructures et ses ententes labé
dans le cas qui nous intéresse ici ce
qu'ils aient cessé ces ententes là un
peu qui sont à la source si on veut de
la controverse puisque parce qu'il y a
des ententes
mais c'est ça il ya des ententes qui ont
été négociés avec les conseils de bande
y compris les conseils de bande de la
nation watts soit il est par contre les
chefs traditionalistes de la nation se
posa saison tentera s'oppose à
l'approbation du projet fnam et se pose
depuis longtemps
ça fait longtemps que les chef
héréditaire expriment de l'opposition à
ce projet de ce fait à peu près une
décennie tout à fait les arrières
nouveau dense à la compagnie le savez le
promoteur du projet le savez le sait
depuis longtemps d'ailleurs les les
documents publics qui en lien avec le
processus d'évaluation du projet on le
voit très bien les chefs traditionnels
ont manifesté leur opposition aux
trajets
projecteur qui étaient proposés ont
proposé un autre trajet pour le gazoduc
dont qui se pose depuis longtemps donc
c'est pas nouveau le gouvernement la
colombie tannique le savez aussi donc on
a pris un risque en quelque part il y en
a en allant de l'avant le malgré cette
position est donc ici un energy
anciennement transcanada a proposé
d'ailleurs un compromis c'est-à-dire de
déplacer le tracé de 3 à 5 km du centre
de guérison unis site hautaine le lieu
de contestation principale des
manifestants colombie britannique
oui c'est ça alors l'ailé en fait les
chefs et dignitaires ont proposé un une
trajectoire alternative qui vont un peu
plus au nord est
la compagnie a racheté cette cette
proposition-là n'apparaît pas rentable
séparant en voilà le coup et serait trop
élevé par les d'un coût de 600 à 800
millions supplémentaires
et là ils ont proposé en fait une
contre-proposition n'y a pas eu d'écho
de la part des et des chefs
traditionnels dans ce cas là est ce que
les choses dans ce cas ci ne se sont pas
bien fait ou est ce qu'on doit repenser
ce type de négociations avec les
communautés autochtones mais je pense
que c'est un peu des deux je pense que
les choses se sont se sont pas bien fait
au sens où la compagnie il ya toujours
une question de gestion du risque dans
ces choses là et la compagnie choisit de
prendre le risque d'aller de l'avant
malgré la possibilité qui est des
contestations du projet y compris des
contestations au niveau judiciaire ont
négocié c'est en tant que la avec les
nations autochtones parce qu'on veut
minimiser le risque financier ouais mais
là on a calculé que la vexer son
intention c'était suffisant de toute
évidence c'était paul k il faut mieux
faire les choses c'est évident il faut
s'assurer que dans lorsqu'elle ces
ententes là sont négociés qu'elles
soient négociés en bonne et due forme
avec les personnes qui ont l'autorité
non seulement légale mais aussi morale
dans la communauté pour donner son
accord la ici ce n'est pas le cas on
comprend qu'il ya des intérêts
divergents à l'intérieur de la
communauté vers vous ce que vous dites
c'est qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus
profondément dans la communauté pour que
ces négociations lors qu'on fonctionne
jusqu'au bout il ya d'une part mais il
ya aussi l'autre aspect qui est les
gouvernements dans ce cas c'est le grand
danic qui compte un peu sur ces ententes
négociées en privé pour donner une
légitimité pour autoriser si on veut le
projet alors que dans le fond la
décision d'autoriser le projet devrait
relever à mon avis mais c'est la vie des
autochtones qui est qui manifestent
devrait relever d'une codécision entre
les autorités canadiennes compétente
dans ce que c'est la province et les
autorités autochtone qui revendique de
façon légitime une autorité sur le
territoire contesté
elle s'apprend des mécanismes de
codécision qui présentement n'existe pas
au canada
quels sont les droits des autochtones en
matière d'exploitation des ressources
sur leur territoire la cour suprême
reconnu entre autres en dalle dans l'art
et delgado qui concerne précisément le
territoire en question a reconnu que les
les systèmes de gouvernance
traditionnelles autochtones avaient
avaient des droits ouverts à tous le
moyen un droit de regard sur ce qui se
passait sur sur leur territoire donc le
droit canadien reconnaît effectivement
d'une part une obligation de consulter
les autochtones concernées mais dans
certains cas lorsqu'il ya un titre
ancestrale qui est en jeu une obligation
d'obtenir le consentement des nations
autochtones l'horizon trans et sera qui
était reconnue ok mais mais il ya des
il ya de fortes possibilités
qu'effectivement ce titre ancestrale
existait pas reconnue en droit mais qui
a préséance
est ce que c'est ce droit donc vous
parler ou au bout du compte les
compagnies minières les compagnies
pétrolières ont souvent le dernier mot
en pratique évidemment l'intérêt
économique tant appris mais ceci dit on
s'entend bien qu'au canada
par exemple le gouvernement fédéral mais
aussi le grand lac aux eaux britanniques
qui vient d'adopter une loi pour la mise
en oeuvre la déclaration des nations
unies
ces droits des peuples autochtones ces
déclarations la prévoit que dans les cas
comme ça les gouvernements doivent
consulter en vue d'obtenir le
consentement des autochtones
donc si on est conséquent avec nos
engagements internationaux si on est
conséquent en matière de réconciliation
avec les peuples autochtones qui est une
priorité du gouvernement est bien
normalement l' équilibre devrait se
faire entre les intérêts économiques
qu'ils étaient des autochtones est là
jusqu'à maintenant disons que c'est
plutôt les intérêts économiques qui ont
tendance à prix mais de façon assez
systématique je dirais certains
papillons vous êtes professeur en
sciences politiques à l'université
montréal merci pour ces explications ce
soir d'un coup